utilizing these protocols in particular
understanding how to make protocols
robust and so on what I'll talk about
him in my talk is a different question
and the question of how do we compose
different randomness expansion protocols
together to try to maximize the amount
of expansion that we can achieve so this
is going to work with Matthew John who's
sitting in the audience and so let me
quickly run through a general model of
randomness expansion protocols that
encompasses a lot of the protocols that
we've seen so far in the literature so
how they generally work is you have a
classical referee some classical user
and the referee starts with some short
uniformly random and bit string so think
of em as small maybe 100 bits or a
thousand bits and the referee enters
acts with two devices and there's
nothing known about the devices other
than that they're not allowed to
communicate but they may share quantum
entanglement and from this M bit string
the referee will compute too much longer
strings and bits and feed these two
inputs to the devices sequentially one
by one and as the referee sends in the
inputs it also collects out the outputs
and at the end of the day the referee
will perform some tests on the inputs
and outputs of the device for example
check to see if the devices when
eighty-five percent or close to eighty
five percent of the games relative to
the CH SH game in this protocol and if
this happens if the devices do pass this
test that the referee performs then we
can certify with high probability that
the outputs of these devices say you
take this string a contains a large
amount of randomness a large amount of
min entropy and furthermore if we wanted
something that was close to uniform we
could apply a randomness extractor on on
this output using a small amount of
additional randomness
so you know for the remainder of the
stock we should think of randomness
expansion protocols as being some
protocol that acts like this or at least
a one-shot form of it so as Carl
mentioned you know we've seen some
exciting advances in the in randomness
expansion over the past several years so
Roger kolbeck first obtained linear
expansion he had a protocol where if you
start with n bits of random seed and you
run a protocol such as the one I
described at the end of the day you can
certify that the output you know has
some constant times n bits of randomness
in it the constant being somewhere
between one and two then pro neo
achieved show that you can obtain
quadratic expansion and finally we know
know that you can with such a protocol
you can achieve exponential expansion
starting with n bits of seed you can run
this protocol and certify that as 2 to
the M bits of randomness in it so when
Matt and I first entered this field
started looking at randomness expansion
the first question that occurred to us
was is there a limit to to how much
randomness expansion you can obtain
using such a protocol and at the time it
wasn't clear i mean maybe there was some
fundamental reason for why exponential
expansion is the best you can possibly
help for and in fact in in work between
myself Matt and Toma boutique we showed
that for a broad class of what I call
non-adaptive protocols there is some
finite limit to the maximum amount of
randomness expansion that you can
achieve in in particular it's doubly
exponential expansion I mean perhaps not
the best found but it shows that there
are some limits and the way you prove
such upper bounds is by exhibiting a
cheating strategy and I won't go into
how we show this it's very simple the
main idea is that if you have a protocol
you try to design a randomness expansion
protocol that starts with too few bits
of randomness and you try to run it for
too long after a while there will be
regularities and in the inputs that that
get sent to the devices and the devices
know this and they can start predicting
which inputs will come in and after that
you're toast you can't hope to certify
any more randomness because they can
produce deterministic outputs that win
the game and pass the test so so this
can't work and and what do I mean by
non-adaptive I mean in the sense that
the inputs to the devices sent at every
round are a function only of the initial
seed that the referee starts with they
can't depend on the outputs that the
devices produce so knowing this well of
course let's talk about adaptive
protocols and so let me talk about sort
of the first attempt that you know most
of us will think of when we first hear
about randoms expansion why can't we
take a protocol such as the positive
Ronnie vidiq protocol or say the Miller
she protocol we start with n bits of
seed run at once we obtain to the M bits
of output randomness your first
inclination would be to recycle this and
send it back into the devices and do the
expansion again you get 2 to the 2 to
the M bits of certified randomness out
why can't we do that well if you think
about it this attempt is fraught with
difficulty so
after the first iteration of this
randomness expansion protocol you go
from n bits to 2 to the M bits of
randomness you try to send it back in
but these 2 to n bits of randomness
aren't random relative to these two
devices after all these two devices
produced the outputs so the worry is
that if you try to do this they would be
able to break predict the outcome or the
inputs that would come into the devices
and and be able to pass your test while
only producing deterministic outputs say
I mean you might hope that you can do
something more clever such as say X
soaring their outputs or do some more
complicated post-processing but I don't
know how to analyze this so instead I'll
take a different approach and we're
going to use the fact say that this
thought I Ronnie Vedic protocol is
quantum secure and what do I mean by
that so this protocol involves two
devices again but we also consider the
presence of an eavesdropper some
adversary that may be entangled with the
two devices it may have manufactured the
devices and this eavesdropper we can
think of as being very interested in
knowing the outcomes of any randomness
expansion protocol that you run and the
property of being quantum secure is such
that if you start with a seed s that is
uniform an independent of the devices
and the adversary then this protocol can
transform this initial seed into an
output that is first of all much longer
but also in tensor close to being tensor
product with the adversary that's what I
mean by being quantum secure and this is
a very neat property and we may hope to
use this fact to to perform such a
composition so now we have four devices
total and we break them up into two
groups and B and we say well let's run
the FA's irani Vedic protocol with group
a and and let's treat these other two
devices as the potential eavesdropper
that may be entangled and so let's run
the visor on ebuddy protocol so we start
with some seed s1
that's mbits long an intensive product
with all the devices involved in the
picture so far we run the VV protocol we
obtain this guarantee we get this output
X 1 that is 2 to the M bits long and
intensive product with Group B well
that's good so far so we can now send
over x1 to the second group your B and
and run the VV protocol again and we get
this output X 2 and we have achieved EE
exponential expansion which is nice and
now our inclination is to send x2 back
into the first group Group a right and
run this process again there's some
conceptual difficulties with this
because as far as the V the analysis of
VV 12 is concerned we can't do this
because we have no guarantee about the
security of this output X 2 against the
original group a as far as we know there
might be some adversarial correlations
shared between X 2 and the devices in
Group A and if we try to run it again we
might not possibly get any randomness
out so it turns out that due to some
work by chung chiu this actually does
work but we didn't know that and we
solved this a different way and and the
way we solve it is you can think of it
as we need to launder the randomness so
we have some quote dirty randomness x2
dirty relative to group a and we need to
need to somehow clean it up so that we
can run it with group a again and
continue this room in this expansion
process and more precisely what do I
mean you know what do I mean by
randomness laundering so the property
that we actually desire is something we
call input security and what's an input
secure protocol it's a protocol such
that you start with a seed s and you
know that the seed is uniform and
independent of the devices that your
interest
running the protocol with but it can be
completely correlated with the adversary
but despite this you would like to still
have the guarantee that the output of
the protocol is still in tensor product
with or close to being tensor product
with the adversary right that's this is
sort of the wishful thinking that we had
and it's it should be clear that if we
had such a input secure protocol then we
can do this composition that I've
described right because we no longer
have this issue of X to not being in
tensor product with a
so the question you might ask well are
are their input secure protocols well we
now know yes but at the time this was
not so clear so an interesting
observation is that for example
extractors are not input secure and
provably so and this is kind of
interesting because in many ways
extractors are analogues of randomness
expansion protocols they have the same
input output structure in the sense that
with an extractor you have a source and
you have a seed and you have an
adversary that you might care about so
it turns out that if you have a seed
that's possibly correlated with an
eavesdropper you can't promise that an
extractor will work and and we have
counter examples well despite this we do
develop an input secure protocol and the
way we do it is as follows so we first
run this buzzer ani vidiq exponential
expansion protocol and it produces some
output that maybe you know you worry
that it still might be entangled with
the adversary because the adversary knew
something about the initial seed you
started with but then we're going to run
something called the ruv extractor to do
this randomness laundering and clean it
up and produce some output X that we can
guarantee is uniform and close to being
in tensor product with the adversary and
this would allow us to achieve it with
security and compose and then we can
compose this protocol together to
achieve unbounded expansion and the
reason we call this our UV extractors
because we rely on a technique and a
tool from a paper of reichardt in
grandma's Ronnie which you've heard
about and this tool is the rigidity of
CH sh games so we've heard about this
already but let me quickly stay what it
is so CH sh rigidity is saying something
about if you have these two non
communicating devices but you have it
play the CH SH game
and you know that the devices win the
game about eighty-five percent of the
time and you don't know what sort of
measurements and what sort of states are
happening here but because of the CH SH
game you can certify that actually the
the measurements that they're making are
the the canonical ideal measurements
that you look need when you learn about
in textbooks and that they're performing
the measurements on an epr state a state
that's intense er product with anything
else everything else in the universe and
what ru v proved was a far-reaching
generalization of this they have what's
called multi game CH SH rigidity and
they say the following so if you have
two isolated devices playing n
sequential CH SH games and you know that
the device is win approximately
eighty-five percent of of them and you
choose a random block of games like as
depicted then what you know is that the
measurements that the device is
performed the strategy that the device
is used to produce the outputs in that
random block is approximately the ideal
product strategy that is in every single
one of these rounds they measured a
tensor tensor product of epr pairs and
this seems really nice right because if
you can certify that they've performed
this ideal strategy on a block then you
know that that outcomes of these
measurements in that particular block
are close to uniform and in tensor
product with with it everything else
right and this gives us hope to design
an input secure protocol so this
suggests a the following protocol so we
take in our dirty randomness that we'd
like to to launder and we know that the
randomness is random relative to these
two devices but may be completely
correlated with a an adversary we have
them play a bunch of CH SH games we
check did they win eighty-five percent
of the games
if so then we select a random block and
by the multi game rigidity statement we
know that with high probability these
blocks this block of games was played
using the ideal strategy so that seems
like we're done right because then we
should be able to include that the block
of bits approximately uniform and in
tensor product with the with the
eavesdropper and voila we get input
security but that's actually it doesn't
immediately follow from the CH SH game
rigidity and the problem is that just
because we know that a particular block
of games was produced using the ideal
strategy it does not imply that that
those outputs are secure conditioned on
passing this protocol and and why is
this the case so here's a depiction of a
whole bunch of block of games and
suppose in blocks 1 through 3 you know
that devices perform the ideal CHS a
strategy in all the rounds but then in
block for what Alice does is she looks
at the XOR of her outputs in block 1 and
if the XOR of her outputs is 0 then she
decides to just play a stupid strategy
for all the remaining games to say she
outputs all zeros otherwise if the XOR
is one that Alice just continues to play
honestly and meanwhile Bob is playing
honestly so with high probability
conditioned on passing this protocol if
they win the proximately eighty-five
percent of the games then you know that
Alice's output in block one is has an
XOR of of one right so Alice's output
and block one is far from uniform
despite block one having been produced
by the ideal strategy so
of course I mean this isn't really a
problem because we're selecting a random
block to start with but the point is you
need to show that you know just because
a block is ideal doesn't mean that it's
secure but we have many idea blocks and
we're selecting one of them at random
and you just do some not too complicated
information theory calculations to show
that with high probability and ideal
block that you select is actually
uniform and secure against the
eavesdropper
okay so another problem is well I've
said that we need to select a random
block of games but who's actually
selecting the random block well where do
we get this randomness to select the
block whoa certainly we can't take it
from the original seed because we only
have some finite amount right we want to
use the outputs the random outputs from
some previous iteration of a protocol to
select this random block and well it's
coming from the adversary so one thing
that you might worry about is that the
adversary will select sort of Adnan say
a non-ideal block of games or a bad
block something that the adversary knows
about but fortunately this also isn't a
problem because using some local
simulation argument the basic idea is
that the two devices that produce these
blocks can also locally compute a
classical description of which blocks
are good and which blocks are bad and
since we have a guarantee on the C
that's being used to select these random
blocks the guarantee that the seat is in
tensor product with the devices we know
that the seed can't select a bad block
of games
so so now that we've taken care of these
problems we now see that how to achieve
unbound you know this composition that
we've been trying to do so we have a lot
of John Ford devices here but really
they're eight what we do is we start
with n bits of seed that we somehow know
our uniform and tensor product with
clusters a and B we run the Maserati
vidiq exponential expansion protocol and
we get to to them bits secure against be
this is promised by the theorem in VV
and then we run this ruv protocol that I
just described and because of this the
randomness laundering capabilities of
our UV we know that we have 2 to the
Omega M bits of randomness that's secure
against all three clusters right despite
only knowing that the inputs was secure
against be alone so so now we compose we
send the outputs to group c we run the
expansion protocol again we get 2 to the
2 to the M bits we run it through our UV
again and now again we have this
guarantee that we have 2 to the M bits
secure against a B and C and we can just
repeat this process
so again and again as many times as you
like and the result is an unbounded
amount of randomness that you certified
starting with only a constant amount of
seed randomness okay so that's our
protocol and of course there are there
other sort of technical issues that you
have to worry about such as the
accumulation of error but these aren't
so bad because at each step of at each
iteration of the protocol the error
decreases exponentially so if you simply
by triangle inequality sum of all the
errors they converge to some small
amount so finally let me mention that
like I said earlier this original
composition that we try to do say taking
two instances of the basmati Vedic
protocol and composing them with each
other well you can't conclude from the
analysis of the VV protocol alone that
you can compose it but it turns out that
you can and this is due to this
equivalence lama by chung chien woo
which we've heard about and it's it's
kind of a very surprising thing it says
if you have a protocol of this
particular form where you require that
the seed s is in tensor product with
both devices and the adversary then you
can obtain some guarantee it turns out
that sort of this automatically implies
you don't need this strong assumption on
the seed and in this room transformation
is sort of black box and and that's
rather surprising so so it turns out
that the VV protocol and this Miller she
protocol are also input secure and the
curious thing is that despite this
transformation we you know we still
can't apply it to classical randomest
extractors because we have a counter
example and and so that I think there's
something curious going on here and
deserves further understanding so
finally let me end with some open
questions and I'm guess I'm dividing my
open questions into two categories and
those categories can be explained by
this comic so so of course you know one
important question that we now have some
answers to is well can we perform robust
random this expansion and and mill oh
she has made some progress in this
direction another question that I find
really interesting is sort of along
different lines is can we perform
randomness expansion with inefficient
detectors where you have you have this
detection loophole and and this is
something that I guess experimentalists
care a lot about because we don't have
perfectly efficient detectors another
question is well what if we allow during
the course of the protocol we have I
mean so far we've assumed that the
devices are not allowed to communicate
with each other I mean in the result of
Miller she they're allowed to
communicate in between rounds but what
if we said you you run this randomness
expansion protocol and they can even
communicate during rounds but you have
some bound on the number of bits that
can be transmitted between them you know
suppose you know that they only Lee K
bits how does that affect the security
of the output are their applications or
generalizations of input security and
finally sort of a question that I kind
of like is can we perform infinite
expansion with only two devices and I
think they'll require some additional
ideas beyond info security so that's all
I have
you understand the last slide about this
why don't afford it yeah this one so why
this what a [ __ ] about 10 SEC strength
is are not in contradiction results
right because the reason is because in
this in this proof because randomness
extractors require that you have an
additional assumption that so I'm
treating we can think of in randomness
extractors the sources d we require that
the source d and the east rapper I mean
the source condition of the ether offer
has some amount of mid entropy and this
doesn't always I mean for arbitrary D&E
this doesn't always always that's the
key point yeah so basically in the
expansion case the assumption is that it
works on all d
t-shirt it works on all the right now in
the exchequer case the assumptions is
that it works on the source and certain
be negative it's not also the source of
your condition so for example if you
would have expansion protocols which say
we have an expansion protocol for quite
bad black boxes but not for all black
boxes then this wouldn't work if you
have an expansion protocol where we
don't guarantee that it works for
malicious boxes but we say like
technologically we can be pretty sure
that we have built this box at least
roughly according to specifications and
right then celebrate this will save you
and kiss any all right you have
constraints are not now you further
works and you
other questions
he does